>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CYRIL.
>>> ALL RIGHT.
SO NEWSLETTER COMPANIES ACROSS
THE UK ARE TRYING TO REASSURE
DRIVERS THAT THEY'RE WORKING
HARD TO KEEP GAS STATIONS
STOCKED.
BRITONS HAVE BEEN SWARMING FUEL
STATIONS FEARING A SHORTAGE, BUT
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE YET.
MANY STATIONS HAVE REALLY RUN
OUT OF GAS DUE TO PANIC BUYING.
WE HAVE NINA SANTOS SEEING THE
MAYHEM FIRSTHAND.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING RIGHT THIS
MINUTE?
>> Reporter: WELL, NOT QUITE
MAYHEM, BUT A FEW TEMPERS THAT
HAVE BEING FRAYED AS PEOPLE
DESPERATELY TRY TO GET THROUGH
THIS ROAD IN CENTRAL LONDON.
THERE'S JUST ONE SMALL PET ROLL
STATION HERE IN THIS PART OF
TOWN THAT HAS BEEN WAITING FOR
DELIVERY SINCE SATURDAY.
EVENTUALLY WHEN IT CAME ABOUT AN
HOUR AND A HALF AGO, AS YOU CAN
SEE THE QUEUE STARTED BUILDING
UP ON ALL SIDES OF THE AREA.
THESE STRETCH BACK AROUND ABOUT
THREE OR FOUR BLOCKS.
YOU ARE HEARING PEOPLE BEEP.
YOU ARE HEARING TAXI DRIVERS AND
DELIVERY DRIVERS SAYING, LOOK, I
DESPERATELY NEED THIS FUEL TO
FULFILL MY ORDERS, I'M LATE ON
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE DAY.
MANY PEOPLE BRANDING THE
SITUATION UNACCEPTABLE AND
SAYING, YES, WE KNOW WE
SHOULDN'T PANIC BUY BUT WE HAVE
TO.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> OBVIOUSLY, YEAH, VERY
CONCERNED, EXTREMELY.
IT IS MY LIVELIHOOD.
AND, YEAH, IT IS OBVIOUSLY A
CONCERN.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF STATIONS
ARE OUT OF FUEL WHEN I TRY.
IT IS JUST LUCKY, THERE'S A
TANKER I SEE AND I JUST PULLED
IN HERE.
NO, IT IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
>> MAYBE ABOUT FIVE PETROL
STATIONS.
NONE OF THEM ARE OPEN.
>> Reporter: ELENI, OF COURSE,
THIS COULDN'T HAVE COME AT A
WORSE TIME BECAUSE REMEMBER A
LOT OF PEOPLE HERE INCLUDING
TAXI DRIVERS IN LONDON, DELIVERY
DRIVERS ARE TRYING TO GET
ECONOMICALLY BACK ON THEIR FEET
AFTER ALL OF THOSE LOCKDOWNS
THAT COST THEM SO DEAR OVER THE
LAST 18 MONTHS OR SO.
SO THIS IS A REAL CONCERN HERE,
THAT THIS COULD START TO DENT
THE POST-COVID RECOVERY.
AS YOU CAN HEAR PEOPLE HONKING
THEIR HORNS EVERY TIME A SLOT
FILLS UP, PEOPLE DESPERATELY
TRYING TO CRAM THEIR CARS IN OR
MOTOR BIKES TO GET IN TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN FILL UP.
THE MANAGER OF THIS PETROL
STATION SAYS BY THE WAY THEY
USUALLY ONLY NEED THREE
DELIVERIES A WEEK TO FULFILL THE
LOCAL NEED, BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS
PROBABLY WILL BE GONE BY THE END
OF THIS EVENING OR PERHAPS BY
EARLY TOMORROW MORNING.
WHAT IS THE GOVERNMENT DOING?
WELL, AS YOU SAID, THEY SAY
THERE'S NO NATIONAL SHORTAGE.
THEY'RE APPEALING TO PEOPLE TO
STOP PANIC BUYING.
THEY'RE TRYING TO ALLEVIATE VISA
RESTRICTIONS TEMPORARILY TO
TEMPT 5,000 HEAVY GOODS DRIVERS
OVER FROM EUROPE AND ALSO WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS CHANGE,
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND COMPETITION
RULES TO ALLOW FUEL MAKERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS TO TALK TO EACH
OTHER, TO DIVERT SUPPLIES TO
PETROL STATIONS LIKE THESE TO
EASY THE BOTTLE NECK IN SUPPLY
AND DEMAND.
ELENI.
>> NINA, THANK YOU FOR THE
UPDATE.
>>> TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING
ON WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
BUSINESS SIDE OF PETROL.
LORENZO ZACCO IS PRESIDENT OFAL
KA LINE WHICH OPERATING LARGELY
ON THE ITALIAN ANGLO MARKET.
THANK YOU AND IT IS GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
YOU SAY PEOPLE ARE RIGHT TO BE
PANICKING AND PANIC BUYING.
WHY?
>> OF COURSE THEY PANIC BECAUSE
THERE'S NO CLEAR INDICATION OF
WHERE WE'RE GOING AT THE MOMENT.
I MEAN THESE GOVERNMENT,
THESE -- FOR THE LAST 15 MONTHS
AND EVERYBODY KNEW THAT EASTERN
EUROPEANS OR THE EUROPEANS WERE
GOING TO GO BACK HOME AND THERE
WAS NO PROVISION FOR THAT.
SO BASICALLY NOW THEY'RE
ANNOUNCING SOMETHING THAT ALMOST
SOUNDS LIKE SUICIDE REALLY
BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GETTING DRIVERS, THE LAST --
SKIP DID NORMAL PROCEDURE, GO
STRAIGHT TO -- AND WHERE YOU GO
WITHOUT CONSIDERING BASICALLY
THEY HAVE TO STOP THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES BECAUSE IF I WAS TO
GET SOMEONE WITH VERY LITTLE
EXPERIENCE, MOST PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BE SHORT AND IF IT WAS
TO BE SURE WOULD RUN OUT OF
MONEY, BECAUSE THE INSURANCE
COMPANY, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
WHAT THEY DO FOR A LIVING,
THEY'RE RISKS.
BASICALLY IT IS A HIGH RISK AND
I DON'T THINK THAT ANYBODY WILL
BE ADDED TO PICK UP THAT KIND OF
RISK.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT MOST
OF -- THEY SAY EUROPEANS,
NON-EUROPEANS.
NON-EUROPEANS, IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE CPC, THE CERTIFICATE OF
PROFESSIONAL COMPETENCE WHICH
THEY HAVEN'T GOT BECAUSE IT ONLY
APPLIES TO EUROPEANS.
THEN WE HAVE TO TAKE
NON-EUROPEANS OUT OF THE
EQUATION.
ALSO, YOU HAVE 5,000, 5,000
DRIVERS.
AND WHERE DO THEY THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO COME FROM?
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT COMING
FROM EUROPE.
THEY'VE BEEN AND GONE.
THEY'RE NOT COMING BACK.
I MEAN THEY LEFT YESTERDAY
BECAUSE THE SHEER CHAOS.
HOW DO YOU EXPECT TO HAVE
SOMEONE WITHOUT OBVIOUSLY --
WITH ABOUT FUEL, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT VERY, VERY FLAMMABLE
COMMODITY LIKE PETROL, WHO
EXACTLY IS GOING TO DO THAT?
>> EXACTLY.
YOU CAN'T REPLACE TRUCK DRIVERS
THAT EASILY, RIGHT?
THAT'S THE THING.
IT IS A SKILL AND YOU NEED
TRAINING AND, AS YOU SAY, YOU
NEED THE INSURANCE.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO LURE
PEOPLE BACK IN TO GET -- TO COME
IN AND WORK.
BUT WHEN YOU DISRUPT A SUPPLY
CHAIN LIKE THIS THAT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH,
HOW QUICKLY CAN IT BE RECTIFIED?
YOU ARE THE MAN IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND YOU UNDERSTAND THE
INTRICACIES HERE.
>> WELL, LISTEN, THE ONLY WAY TO
DO THAT, BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
JUST PLAY THE SAME GAME AS THE
HIGH STREET RETAILERS, THE
SUPERMARKETS HAVE DONE IN THE
LAST TWO MONTHS BECAUSE THEY
STARTED TO PANIC THEMSELVES,
OFFERING RIDICULOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY LIKE 5,000 POUNDS IN CASH
UP FRONT OR WHETHER IT
MERCEDES-BENZ 1,000, 2,000, 300
OR RIDICULOUS LIKE 50,000,
60,000, AS SUGGESTED AS WELL.
SO BASICALLY MONEY THAT NO ONE
HAS BECAUSE, LIKE OURSELVES, WE
HAVE 3% MARGINS AND THE DRIVER
COST RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT 29% OF
OUR COST.
SO WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR THAT?
I MEAN THAT'S ANOTHER BIG
QUESTION MARK.
THERE'S SOMEONE LEFT TO ANSWER
FOR THAT BECAUSE ALL THEY HAVE
TO DO NOW, BASICALLY THE FUEL
COMPANIES HAVE TO PAY AN EXTRA
10,000 POUNDS CASH.
AND, BELIEVE ME, WITHIN A WEEK
EVERY SINGLE TANKER IN THE LAND
WILL BE UP AND RUNNING.
>> SO GIVE IT TO US SIMPLY.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS AS,
YOU KNOW, THE UK GOVERNMENT IS
TRYING TO GET IN MORE DRIVERS
AND TRYING TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
AND YOU SEE MORE PANIC BUYING,
WHAT ARE THE REPERCUSSIONS HERE?
BECAUSE, AGAIN, WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE MORE THAN
JUST A FEW MEASURES, YOU KNOW,
TO PUT IN PLACE TO GET DRIVERS
BACK.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
DRIVERS, L HORRY DRIVERS, IT IS
NOT A GOOD JOB ANYWAY.
IT IS BADLY PAID.
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO PROSECUTION
EVERY DAY THEY GET ON THE ROAD.
THEY HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
IMMIGRATION COMING INTO UK.
HE THEY'RE TREATED LIKE SCUM AND
BASICALLY WHO WANTS TO DO THAT
JOB?
THEY'RE LOW PAID.
I MEAN YOU GET THE SAME SORT OF
MONEY JUST LUGGING SHELVES OF
SUPERMARKETS.
BASICALLY -- AND THEN THEY'RE
AWAY FROM THE FAMILY.
SOCIETY HAS CHANGED.
BASICALLY DRIVERS DON'T WANT TO
BE AWAY FOR DAYS AND WEEKS ON
END.
THEY WANT TO BE PART OF THE
FAMILY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT
IS.
IT HAS CHANGED.
SO BASICALLY NOBODY IS PREPARED
TO DO THAT UNLESS YOU ARE GOING
TO PAY A RIDICULOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
REALLY, REALLY GOOD MONEY.
AT THAT POINT YOU WILL FIND THEM
THAT WANT TO DO IT.
OTHERWISE I MEAN WE'VE GOT IN
THE REVENUE IN UK, BASICALLY
THEY'RE PAYING WORLD RECORD
HIGHS, ABOUT 5 POUND AND MEAL
ALLOWANCES AND THAT'S THE WHOLE
DAY, TAX FREE.
I MEAN FIVE POUNDS YOU'RE NOT
GETTING FAR THESE DAYS.
YOU ARE LUCKY IF YOU GET A
CHEESE BERGER.
WE WILL BE STARVING THE REST OF
THE DAY.
GOING BACK TO THE OTHER DRIVERS,
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE BASICALLY
GOING TO HAVE DRIVERS FROM
EUROPE.
THEY WILL BE WORKING FOR TEN
WEEKS IN UK AND WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO, SEND THEM BACK?
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THAT THESE
DRIVERS HERE, THEY'RE JUST GOING
TO LEAVE A STABLE JOB IN EUROPE
TO COME AND WORK IN UK, MORE OR
LESS FOR THE SAME MONEY, AND
THEN BE THROWN BACK LI